hi
good to see you uh i'm gonna say uh nice
to see you
and thank you guys for making an
entertaining movie um
i wanted to so i want to start with what
i think is awesome which is that you
guys have
apparently been friends since like 1973.
i might be wrong about the year but it's
been you know it's been a little while
um but i am curious what how long have
you guys actually been friends because
i think it's amazing like 25 years yeah
a long time very long time
do you remember where you guys first met
can you share that oh yeah
yeah i would go to the groundlings to
watch
uh melissa and ben um uh and
our friend tate taylor i would go watch
them on stage that's how we met
yeah she had the best laugh in the
audience and she would come all the time
and then the other other the other
performers were literally called before
the show and they're like
is your friend octavia coming it's very
important she be in the audience
because her laugh would literally make
the whole audience laugh more so she was
like the best plant ever
i am curious uh octavia um if ma
was in a superhero or super villain what
kind of person would she be
if ma were a superhero or super villain
yeah i think she'd be somewhere in
between that
um you know uh because she's a person
who killed people
and so i i don't know that she
she there's any sort of heroism in that
so yeah she would probably just be a
super villain come to think of it
she would be so scary with powers yeah
she was scary without powers
uh when you saw jason bateman and his
crab claws
were you like i why can't i be having
those crab claws
because that was to me amazing
um ben just kept looking at me and like
the whole time it was like okay now
we're having a vfx thing about this and
then there's
someone's coming in they're like hi i'm
going to do the molds or the crab arms
ben just kept looking at me he goes
clearly at some point someone from
netflix is going to call and say
you can't actually do this and then
there was like a model
like models were made he's like this
seems to keep
going and then when he was actually
standing in those incredible arms that
like really he could operate and
everything we were like
it's like a fever dream i was so happy
to see
him in them and they made me laugh they
looked so cool but they were also just
so weird
that i loved it uh i i do have to ask
melissa an individual question for you
if you don't mind which is um
what is actually cooler being in the new
thor movie
or playing ursula in a live-action
little mermaid
well i'm i'm ursula is the only thing i
know that i'm contracted to do
got it got it
okay real fast um uh i would imagine
making this was a blast can you each
share just really quick like a memorable
moment from filming
a day you'll never forget i know what it
is for me
octavia is wonderfully gentle
incredibly powerful as an actress but
there's a gentleness to her personality
like i'm more like [ __ ] and blah blah
blah
that tv's just there's a gentle presence
so after the big explosion in the diner
when we go out and i stop the bus
ben i thought was going to knock himself
out laughing you know what i'm gonna say
don't you
she kept running out and she even she
runs kind of gently
and she was supposed to be we all
expected it to be like fireforce needs
his bust and like stop it and she ran
out in the first take
literally she ran out and gently went
the fourth season bus
and literally you just saw crew like go
down
people were like oh and then that's all
we could hear and then we had it on a
loop and we were just playing
it and then constantly to this day still
goes
metaphors he's about
that's so funny and i was like
everything i do i feel like
i'm so gruff and aggressive but that
octavia is like my polar opposite she's
just like gentle and well thought out
but that was mine when it's yours wrong
oh my god
i think it was uh when you first started
doing the training
and um you were jumping up
just watching you do the wire work
jumping up on the the high jump thing
um god just all of that but every day
honey
every day was an adventure and fun it
was so fun
it was a blast that's for sure on that
note thank you both so much for your
time
and have a fantastic day bye good to see
you